we begin with this is a very disturbing
story from Allah from Alaska where an
Alaska teenager is charged with
murdering her best friend for a
multi-million dollar payday from a
stranger that she met online
Cynthia Hoffman was killed earlier this
month police say the man posed online as
a millionaire and then offered the
suspect money to commit a murder and
send him pictures of it Jonathan
Vigliotti is at Thunderbird Falls
trailhead that's outside of Anchorage
where Hoffman's body was found Jonathan
good morning and good morning to you
Cynthia Hoffman was lured to this trail
under the guise of going for a hike one
day after she was reported missing
police found her body bound with duct
tape along the riverbed not too far from
where we are right now what makes this
story all the more disturbing according
to authorities all five teenagers were
motivated by money promised to one of
them by a man met online thousands of
miles away facing a judge 18 year old
Denali Bremer seemed to have nothing to
hide
Bremer and sixteen-year-old Caden
McIntosh are charged with murder in the
death of 19-year old Cynthia Cece
Hoffman according to court documents it
all started when Bremer struck up an
online relationship with 21 year old
Darren shill Miller who lives in Indiana
he claimed he was a millionaire named
Tyler and instructed her to murder
someone and send photos and videos in
exchange for nine million dollars he did
not name a target Bremer offered four
other friends a cut of the money for
their help authorities say Bremer and
McIntosh Lord Hoffman on a hike the teen
was then shot in the back of the head
and put into a river addressing the
court Hoffman's father said his daughter
was developmentally disabled and just
wanted to be accepted the only thing I
know is that my daughter trusted these
people my daughter just wanted friends
now I have to bury her and that is wrong
you could ruin your entire life in a
matter of minutes based on what you see
what you do and how you react to people
online cyber security expert Adam Levin
says young people are especially
vulnerable parents should be saying to
kids be very careful of someone who gets
too close too fast someone who asks you
for way too much information about you
and do not believe everything you see or
hear online federal authorities say Sean
Miller also convinced Bremer to sexually
assault two minors the two are now also
facing child pornography charges
Anthony Jonathan Vigliotti thanks
Jonathan what a disturbing case one of
the most sickening stories I heard and
it's interesting when he says parents
need to tell their children X Y & Z you
wouldn't think you have to tell your
children if someone asks you to murder
somebody for money don't do that this is
not a very this is not only about the
internet there was recruitment online
but then the four friends went along
they're local and the girl who's accused
of pulling the trigger yes she wasn't on
line 16 who's doing what a friend said